after the first teaser to Aladeen gains
a small shitstorm regarding the color of
the genie a few days ago a real trailer
was now published however the criticism
seems Disney to have taken to heart
because with the first longer trailer a
lot has been done right the interplay of
costumes humor and music now looks much
more harmonic and to the taste of many
fans you can also see this in the
numbers of views since the trailer could
already record more than 4 million
streams in less than 24 hours we don't
have to wait too long anymore because
already on May 24th we are allowed to
see Guy Ritchie's alledon in the cinema
the superhero film Captain Marvel set a
new record at the box office with brie
Larson in the leading role this is even
the most successful start of a film with
the female cast of all times as in the
first few days four hundred and fifty
five million u.s. dollars were earned
even compared to DC's Wonder Woman
Captain Marvel is miles ahead now of
course it's time for Marvel to look
ahead and after the sensational result
it's not too surprising that there are
speculations about the second part of
the blockbuster in the room and although
nothing has been officially announced
yet Marvel boss Kevin Feige leaves no
doubt that there will be a sequel
according to him Captain Marvel will
continue to be the most powerful heroine
in the MCU in the future so the second
part could play after Captain Marvel but
before the popular Avengers endgame
everything else you can leave in good
faith in the hands of Marvel after all
the Marvel team knows very well how they
can amaze and surprise their fans each
time nevertheless before we talk about
the second part we should wait until
April 26 when Avengers end game starts
at u.s. cinemas finally there is a start
date for the second season of popular
one punch man soon you will be able to
see a young hero Saitama in action of
the swimming platform Hugh Liu again
parallel to the Japanese release all
those who haven't seen the first season
yet can now do so on Netflix
fans who are looking forward to season
two have to be prepared for a change
since director Shingo Natsume announced
his retirement last year there will
certainly be some changes with Chikara
Sakurai as the new director release date
on the stream platform Hulu is on April
and 2019 when you think of Stephen King
films like the Shawshank Redemption the
Green Mile or it and Pet Sematary come
to mind now a new film adaption of his
work The Talisman will be released the
film is about what Raphael Jack whose
mother Lily is about to die after he has
been accommodated in a hotel with her on
the run from a former business partner
of his father he meets the mysterious
speedy Parker who teaches little Jack
that he can save his mother if he
travels not only through half of the USA
but also through mysterious territories
in search of a legendary talisman
originally the great Steven Spielberg
had secured the right to the book
however he never filmed it but now he
and his company Amblin entertainment
have contracted Fargo and ten mates tell
director Mike Parker for the talisman
the talisman is now the fourth mention
Stephen King horror novel after it pet
cemetery and the shining secret doctor
sleep which will either be released this
year or is in the works after Black
Mirror Bandersnatch Netflix plans to
release many more interactive films in
the future even though Bandersnatch was
a complete innovation in the streaming
industry and the story was not well
received by everyone we can hope for
more interactive content in the future
Tod Yellin from Netflix commented at the
press conference that they have realized
that interactive storytelling is
something Netflix wants to focus on in
the future he also adds that more
interactive stories can be expected in
the next one or two years new content
for Disney's own streaming service
Disney places in the pipeline
according to slash film a series of the
serious what if commissioned by Kevin
Feige will be created as in the comic
series under the same name the focus
will be on alternative story ends such
as what would happen if Thanos joined
the Avengers or what would happen if
Loki found Taurus hammer ideally the
actors of the reel films should speak
the characters of the what-if series in
order to point out alternative action
possibilities and exits the series which
is based on the comic original from 1977
is primarily intended to pick up MCU
content with the realization of this
idea Disney naturally wants to create
more and more exclusive content for its
streaming service Disney Plus which will
be released at the end of the year
currently in production is a serious
about the former life of Loki staring
Tom Hiddleston in December of the
waiting has come to an end the third
part of the Jumanji saga will be shown
in the cinemas the rock posted a picture
with his colleagues Kevin Hart Karen
Gillan and Jack like on Instagram in the
first moment no big change to the second
part except that there doesn't seem to
be much left of the green jungle scenery
and even if you look at the cast some
news reveal itself
for example rapper aquafina Donald
Glover and Daniel DeVito joined the cast
another great thing is that Bebe
Neuwirth who played the ond of the two
children in the original Jumanji with
Robin Williams should also return to the
camera
however this information has to be taken
with caution
as it is unconfirmed so far anyway you
can expect a trailer soon which might
reveal a little bit more as the release
date is already on December 13 2009
[Music]